كورونا عود على بدء لا يتعلق الامر هذه
المره بتفش جديد للفيروس وانما باستدعاء
اسئله البدايات عن المنشا والملابسات وفق
صحيفه
فان وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه خلصت الى
احتمال ان يكون كوفيد
التسرب عربي من معهد علم الفيروسات الصيني
في ووهان وقد جاء الاستنتاج استنادا الى
تقرير استخباراتي سري قدم اخيرا الى البيت
الابيض واعضاء في الكونغرس لم يكشف عن
مصدر التقرير لكن صحيفتين اكدتا ان وزاره
الطاقه اصدرت حكمها بثقه منخفضه ورجح ضمنا
ان تكون الوزاره قد اعتمدت في استنتاجها
على شبكه المختبرات التي تشرف عليها بما
فيها تلك التي تجري ابحاثا بيولوجيه
متقدمه وسرعان ما ردت الخارجيه الصينيه
على الاتهام
على الاطراف المعنيه التوقف عن اثاره
الادعاءات بشان التسريبات المختبريه والكف
عن تشويه سمعه الصين وتسييس الابحاث
المتعلقه بمنشا الفيروس
الاستنتاجات العلميه الموثوقه التي توصل
اليها خبراء مشتركون من الصين ومنظمه
الصحه العالميه لم تعثر على اي دليل يؤكد
احتمالات تسرب الفيروس
تعليقا على هذا الجدل الامريكي الصيني
قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه انها ستواصل
مراجعه جميع الادله العلميه المتاحه التي
يمكن ان تساعد في كشف حقائق الفيروس
وبينما دعت المنظمه الصين والمجتمع العلمي
لاجراء الدراسات اللازمه اعتبرت ان جميع
الفرضيات تبقى قائمه
الاستنتاج الجديد يتقاطع مع موقف مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكي اف بي اي
القائل ايضا بتسرب الفيروس من مختبر صيني
لكن التقرير يتباين مع استنتاجات اربع
وكالات استخباراتيه امريكيه اخرى رجحت
بثقه منخفضه ايضا ان يكون منشا الفيروس
طبيعيا وامام هذه الاحكام المتباينه في
مجتمع الاستخبارات اكد جيك سوليفان مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي اللا وجود لاجابه
نهائيه
حتى الان عن اصل كورونا وان اداره بايدن
ستبلغ الكونغرس والجمهور حاله توفر تلك
المعلومات
وكما الحال في كل عام من المرتقب ان يطلع
قاده مجتمع الاستخبارات في الولايات
المتحده الكونجرس في مارس المقبل بما
لديهم من معلومات سريه بما في ذلك تلك
المتعلقه بجائحه كوفيد التي ظهرت قبل
ثلاثه اعوام واودت بحياه نحو سبعه ملايين
انسان